someday we will hopefully find out the
truth about what a flick Donald Trump
and what is responsible for his
increasingly erratic behavior and the
speech trouble and the memory trouble
but for now all we have are experts who
are sounding the alarm based on his
publicly available behavior and we've
been talking about this for years and
slowly but surely the discussion is
moving more and more to mainstream
places we now have a series of mental
health professionals starting with a
psychologist from New York City a Ben
Michaelis who did an analysis of Donald
Trump's vocabulary over time and what he
found is that trumps vocabulary has
become more and more simple over time
with deteriorating sentence structure
and numerous experts believe that this
is indeed surprised a sign of cognitive
decline by the President of the United
States now some are arguing well you
know he's getting to be in his mid 70s
there might be some a speech decline
that would be observable in anybody that
age and that sometimes does happened but
again mental health professionals saying
that what Trump is experiencing what he
is exhibiting exceeds just age-related
cognitive decline when you look at 80
plus year old attorney Alan Dershowitz I
don't agree with the word the guy says
lately but you see a drastic difference
in cognitive function when compared to
Donald Trump
relative to both of their baselines when
you go and look at five and ten year old
videos of them a lot of people seem to
forget that Donald Trump used to be very
articulate the psychologist Ben
Michaelis says that some deterioration
in a 73 year old would not be hugely
surprising although not a requirement by
any means but that what we are seeing
exceeds that john montgomery is also a
psychologist and says that Trump must be
tested so that we can know what's going
on and says quote I think it's pretty
safe to say that Trump has had
significant cognitive decline over the
years neuropsychologist sterling Johnson
says it could be stress-related
cognitive decline it could be related to
neuro degenerative
degenerative that's difficult to say
neurodegenerative disease or now I'm
thinking I've cognitive decline or
normal cognitive decline that comes with
aging we've talked about the slurring of
words we've talked about the dilated
pupils even in bright rooms with
professional stage lighting we've talked
about all of these instances and this
could be anything from a dementia type
decline to drug use to the side effects
of pharmaceutical medications to
anything in between
there's also notably the difference
between the two trumps we've talked
before about upper Trump the guy
tweeting hundreds of times a day and
retweeting speaking quickly at events
with the rapid sniffing and then there's
downer Trump tired slurring low-energy
Trump very slowly reading the
teleprompter
there's the misstating people's names
and words everything from you know Tim
Apple to Maryland Lockheed to wanting
the oranges of an investigation
sacrifice every day for the furniture
the future of their children I hope they
now go and take a look at the oranges or
the oranges of the investigation that we
appreciate it very much Tim Apple
Maryland Lockheed Mike Bolton as you
know is in Russia Mike bounds justice
[Music]
the Continental Congress created a
unified army our army man da Rand the
ramparts it took over the airports
there's those shoulder spasms that
coincide with the mixed up or mistaken
words that we've observed and shelter
critical look look wait and let me begin
by wishing you a beautiful emigrants
decided to shield and shelter
look look wait you have criminals all
right watching the president here in
Wildwood New Jersey I just wanna get a
quick comment before we toss it over to
Tucker Molly there's the times that his
tongue seems to sort of get in the way
of his teeth
like in this example your campaign of
terror murder mayhem will not be
tolerated any longer it will one more
example of that to show you based on the
core principles of fairness and
reciprocity what they can name it
whatever they can name it peaches and
God bless the imagination
these are episodes of some kind we just
don't know exactly what and you know we
need to be consistent we said Bernie
Sanders said he'd release his full
medical records I said earlier today he
should do it because he promised to do
it and we should know Donald Trump said
he would release his taxes and he hasn't
done it he should do it because he said
he would and Donald Trump should
actually be examined properly and fully
for what's going on here there's just
too many experts here everything from
urologists to mental health
professionals and everything in between
saying something is going on these are
clear consistent symptoms the cause we
don't know and it needs to be
investigated I want to give a quick
shout-out to one of our sponsors VIN
Chara watches they're giving my audience
15% off your entire order when you go to
david pakman.com slash watch maybe you
don't usually wear a watch and you've
been thinking about looking for one to
elevate your look or you've been
thinking about replacing the one you
have check out VIN Charo it's an
American company all of their watches
are built in small batches from high-end
materials they look amazing and they
look like something you'd spend a lot of
money on but ever even chero watch
ranges from a hundred and fifty to three
hundred dollars I went on their website
and picked out the kairos in white and
silver really loved the look the
combination of the white face and the
beige band really loved this one they
also sent me the Kyros limited release
gold reserve set totally different style
this one would make a fantastic gift for
a couple people I can think of in my
family any time you see me wearing a
watch on the show
I'm wearing a van Shara watch go through
their collection I know you'll find
something you like and you'll get 15%
off when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch